Vanessa Bryant is thinking about her
daughter's future our responsibility is
to always inspire and try to take some
of the life lessons that we have learned
and share those with the next generation
so that they can start their journey
with a leg up Kobe Bryant's Widow filed
legal docs to add her in Kobe's eight
month-old daughter Capri to the trust he
established to provide for his family in
the event of his death according to the
court documents obtained by ET the trust
was first set up in 2003 and was updated
several times over the years usually
following the birth of each of their
children but the couple had not updated
the trust following the birth of their
infant daughter before Kobe's shocking
death in a helicopter crash alongside
his 13 year old daughter Gianna and
seven others who were all enroute to the
momba Academy now vanessa is looking to
rectify the oversight and is requesting
a court order to include their baby girl
according to the docs the couple's other
children 17 year old Natalia and three
year old Bianca are entitled to
discretionary distributions of income
and principle during Vanessa's lifetime
vanessa is also in the midst of a
wrongful death lawsuit which she filed
against Island Express the company that
owns the helicopter that crashed on
January 26 in Calabasas California
killing all on board according to the
legal documents obtained by et vanessa
is claiming that the aircraft and pilot
were negligent and that the chopper was
unsafe to x-ray a proof if are you
transitioning and VFR condition you're
[ __ ] up - sniffing what dollars are
the five market correctly the lawsuit
alleges that the helicopter was only
allowed to fly under visual flight rules
and on the day of the crash conditions
were not conducive the afar's visual
flight rules meaning that you're flying
visually outside references singing
mountains hills whatever the National
Transportation Safety Board is still
investigating the cause of the crash
we're not just focusing on weather here
though we take a broad look
at everything around an investigation
and around an accident we look at
man-machine and the environment and
weather is just a small portion of that
[Music]